you are about to enjoy a free preview
from marvel studios thor love and
thunder
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hey who'd you piss off now it's not my
fault i've never even seen these things
whatever hell they are welcome back
[Music]
who's the new guy for that guy
you're gonna love that guy
[Music]
[Music]
you're back
really
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
excuse me hello that's my hammer you've
got there
[Applause]
and that's my look
hey
enough tomfoolery why don't you take up
that mask and reveal yourself come on
hey
jane
let me tell you the legend of thor and
jane
he was a god of thunder and she a woman
of science
and although they were from different
worlds
[Music]
somehow it just made sense
together they embarked on a journey of
love
[Music]
thor taught jane the way of the warrior
and jane taught thor the way of the
people
and as time passed their love grew
deeper and deeper
[Music]
she's incredible
i need you to promise me
you'll always protect her
and i love you too buddy
and love that deep as a wave becoming
magical
thor set his sights towards a future and
all it might hold
[Music]
but the more he pondered a life with
jane the more he feared losing that life
and although jane didn't want to admit
it she was scared of loss as well
[Music]
and so they built walls between them
thor got busy saving humanity
[Music]
jane got busy doing the same
real busy
and eventually the space between them
grew and grew until it became too wide
to bear
[Music]
something had to give i have to stay up
all night
go through this data
and clean all of this up
and then one night it did give
jane wrote a note
and thor read that note
and their legend suddenly became myth
or so they thought
you okay
yeah
just a little uh hot and
feel
started
he's claustrophobic with the
helmets
[Music]
how
can we talk about this later
yeah sure great seeing you
what
[Music]
[Music]
uh
hey is that the necro sword that's cool
i've only ever read about in stories and
you know this is going to uh
pain
what is playing the construct invented
by the weak okay
hey
don't touch my things
yeah you better run your coward
[Applause]
the children they're taking the children
[Music]
see what happens next order the entire
movie marvel studios thor love and
thunder now available
you